as you can tell we are like playing
already Michael's in a helicopter I'll
show you guys that in a second welcome
to GameSpot live thank you all for
tuning in I'm gonna play Just Cause for
you're actually gonna be reviewing Just
Cause for I sure am that correct so I
think that should hopefully be in the
next what day yeah I'm aiming to have my
review up tomorrow because we did get
code pretty late I did spend the weekend
playing this game so I think I know what
the deal is all right here we go
oh this is a good spot for the PIP I
that's an accidental okay I will take it
um so yeah thank you all for choosing
Ward this game comes out tomorrow or I
guess tonight technically shrikes 9 p.m.
where 12 a.m. depending on what's going
on this week is gonna be crazy though
for a lot of like other games of service
games as I mentioned I think destinies
DLCs tomorrow battlefields got a tank
you'll see I think oh yeah the rolling
up fortnight's got something going on
there I know right favorite but here we
are just cause poor you're in a
helicopter I am we're pretty much your
open-world exploring right at this point
pretty much ooh also the homie what the
hell why the shootin at me though
oh you know why maybe they're like oh yo
you're a bad bad ink that guy's
helicopter oh well alright let's blow
some stuff up that's always all about
right that's what just causes about
alright so yeah this is just cause for
if you're not familiar with just cause
poor it's an open-world action game with
starring Rico Rodriguez who is always
taking down oppressive dictators and
always trying to make the world a better
place and by blowing stuff up that is
marked with red I can create chaos I
already destroyed that so whatever
alright so yeah we're gonna be doing a
couple different things here right now
I'm just trying to warm myself up with
the helicopter controls blow some stuff
up but I actually finished this game
last night
okay so I have no mission stories to
play that's fair but you got you said we
can do some side objectives and
watch this helicopter blow up maybe not
I gotta I gotta focus on flying here so
the thing with Just Cause 4 or just
cause in general is that the the
traversal system is one of the best
parts of this game as you can see Rico
Rodriguez here he can run around he
can't sprint but that doesn't matter
because he has a grappling yeah I mean
you don't need to run in when you could
do that this kind of [ __ ] parkour he's
got a parachute he's got a wingsuit and
the combination of those three things
you can do some wild things man so yeah
this is probably my favorite parts like
especially during missions where it's
like oh I need a vehicle nah man look at
this boom boom boom let's go had all the
silly stuff that like all those hot
gifts that come out we're like their
tether in like random [ __ ] to other [ __ ]
and then blowing [ __ ] up and then just
like watching it all spin out of control
yeah well let's try something a little
bit here so tether oh she's now get ran
over get ran over that's why you gotta
look both ways when you cross the street
i'ma tether this fool up here oh sorry
hey safe that's messed up okay oh okay
and also it's in the arm Oh
oh snap I didn't know I gathered yeah
let's keep tethering Fuu all right it's
kind of got that like metal gear full oh
hey only last for so long oh god that
person's so dead Wow I'm assuming
they're all right I'm assuming we're not
a murderer
No Rico's Rico gonna do some darks dark
[ __ ] out here Oh
r.i.p my bad dawg well let's send them
off to to the heavens my bad dawg
rip alright alright legit you just
killed this man twice oh look at that
ragdoll game is so messed up there are a
dark man and we just started oh we've
only just begun Michael Sam yeah you can
do some pretty messed up things here and
just cause but you know what we're gonna
keep doing messed up things
cuz that's what it's about the power Oh
Rico come on
at least that's fair you get faceplant
as you grappled there so you know yeah
yeah I'm gonna be probably messing
around with some of the grappling hook
and physics stuffs okay because that is
the one of the new features of this
cause for so you know all about
tethering and grappling hooks it's
played one of these games before but the
special thing is is I'll go into the
menu here is that you can mod your
grappling hook so there's three
different things you can do get up
airlifters you can have a retractor and
boosters so these are just booster jets
okay make things go fast and then the
retractor pulls things together like
violently and air lifter is those
balloons that we were seeing you could
set it to automatically two things when
you shoot your grappling hook you can
set it to where you tap tap up and then
will activate or you can hold up and
it'll activate and you can combine these
things so it's gonna get why a key wild
then some people are gonna go gray they
can for the purposes of actually playing
this game like effectively I've
separated those three because I feel
like it's easier for me to kind of
switch between them you use them when I
want to but you know we can still do
some crazy stuff let's see let's put
some booster gel okay check this [ __ ]
out
let's put some booster jet someone oh
he's got a booster jet boom peace out
dawg
oh no oh he's still flying alright and
we can deactivate it oh you can you save
him midtech
oh nope he just dead oh damn I bet I
shouldn't like have a murder count oh
jeez yeah well to keep up with all
that's like at least two people dead
alright let's put two boosters on them
now let's put three boosters on them
boom peace out dawg I don't know man hi
I guess not do you know rip oh like one
of those like firecrackers gone bad you
know it's like spinning out of control
dirty arty yeah this is like just dirty
we go yeah I think just fell did he oh
geez oh alright no oh now he's all you
super dead oh they're like oh no he
ain't dead he dead for sure now man
oh oh that's messed up just taking it Oh
what are we gonna do the helicopter oh I
was trying to see if the booster Jets
are strong enough to propel the
helicopter I haven't gone it must have
been Oh what happened to it damn my bad
so yeah also there's um there's also
mods you can do to your grappling hook
so not only can you set them to like
although I want it to be super fast well
I want to be slow or like moderately
fast and what can i what conditions do
they activate but you can edit them come
on so I haven't unlocked all of them yet
I've only for this one I've only
unlocked acceleration so you can set to
how fast you want to accelerate so I'm
set it so fast
it also said um - what direction they
boost in how long they last what
direction they go I like all of these
example videos yeah they're pretty good
and it's airlifter let's see let's look
at the mods airlifter so I have floating
oh I am set the fragile I want it set to
indestructible there we go well dirty
Rico the son of dirty arty perhaps the
long-lost brother of Arthur Morgan nah
actually nope because they're in
different timelines is there a day one
patch tomorrow there should be okay it's
great I said there's a day one pad but
you had mentioned there's a pixelation
and some of the colors are wrong and
there's some pop in ya as well as
framedrops should be a passion it's
actually been running pretty smooth
there's graphical glitches but I mean
there they don't have honestly like I
haven't run into anything game breaking
I got stuck in geometry but I can get
out pretty fast so many customizations
as my floor is yes there's a lot to play
around with I suppose yeah we can't the
map yeah well I got the map here so I've
unlocked all the regions because I
finish this game sorry if it's spoilers
but I mean yeah people just call since
last week at NASA
cause just cause so yeah these are all
the regions and they have some really
good set pieces here like you have a
like in coastal island here and then you
have like a more tropical area and then
you got snowy mountains which I like a
lot and then you have snow storm deserts
because the whole thing which just cause
for is weather and whether or not we can
see some of that is gonna be yes we're
on the PC version yes is PC let's let's
do a side pitch he is using a xbox
controller but doesn't matter we're
playing PC you want to do a side mission
dog let's do one all right let's see so
I've completed the main story so I won't
be doing any story missions but we do
have Sorento who's our right-hand man
and we can do some let me drop in quick
all right y'all ready for some fortnight
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah we dropping out of a
plane mean so sorry head though is one
of our right-hand man and he gives you a
bunch of side missions which are mildly
interesting I think but we'll see how
these are I haven't done all of them yet
getting ready for battle royale here
yeah just cause battle royale man this
would a I'm tough that would be actually
though like with all the gadgets like
yeah I guess they would have to just
like lower some of that stuff there's
action happening down there don't even
know what's up down there
yeah it's maybe we'll see a tornado I
don't know Just Cause 2 had a
multiplayer mod that I thought was
pretty dope and yeah some people are
saying that if there's multiplayer I'll
have to probably I'm wanted in right
yeah yeah let's see what our hint though
wants and we tested framerate on
consoles not yet getting our console
version still today we've only got PC
codes all right I think this most of
these are like kind of like mom man mama
datte me up so I'm sorry I thought what
you got for me
oh yeah escort yeah I got a escort these
two fools so the black hand is the
corrupt private military organization
that is oppressing the people throughout
just cause a scone wants to know do you
think you can run
Just Cause for on a GTX
60 yep I was for the purposes of my
review I was playing on a gtx 1070 nice
and I was running 1080p pretty much
everything maxed out and I've had
minimal frame drops maybe when there's
like big explosions yeah and all that
but yeah it's been running pretty pretty
well cool and yeah for those people that
are probably gonna ask at some point we
are in a 1070 as well my bad y'all I got
kill you know oh my that guys still goin
bro
oh but he's got to be dead though like
he's gonna get up and start shooting at
me okay look at how he died
that's horrifying I know it is my bad
alright where are these black hand
equipments where's their equipment where
is that what oh they're in the sky oh
it's up here alright whatever
alright let me retract yeah so just
cause has become a physics playground
because of the new physics system that
they've implemented for this game and it
makes for some very janky but good
moments I've been having a good time
watching the booster just take people
for the wild gooses are good man oh I
messed up my car though look good let me
see if I can lift my car at an
out-of-place
let's try and see you go oh it's not
gonna pop there oh right yeah so much
for saving my car I need two passenger
seats maybe he can get into the truck
bed of this this guy's like dude wrong
spot and not even look at this oh no
it's fine everything's ok he good he
doesn't feel it everything's fine oh oh
what's all right what let's send him to
the heavens there's nice what my I
thought my stuff was set to
indestructible oh well you can get into
the back of this
come on let's see if the AI is these
commas just like nope no I can't I need
two passenger seats all right grab that
cart I just got stuck on the other side
actually let me show you a feature while
we're at it okay let's do some supply
drops this is kind of cool
we can so as you got timers yeah okay
yes so you have several people who can
just basically drop you anything you
want
look at that so Fortuna here can I set
her to drop me a armored truck so uh you
know what let's drop it he said so much
for saving the car I know right I
thought it was a good plan I cannot
believe that that thing blew up from the
a way it wasn't even that honest but it
doesn't matter because I have an
infinite supply of vehicles because the
supply drops thanks to its like it's
like we never lost it really really yeah
all right
do they not get in unless like your
closing oh my lord
I think I Hawk the horn they can start
most wrong I think this thing can plow
through this oh sure yeah I'm not
opposed to that man do you do you all
right now I gotta find the next
Blackhand installation Oh hundred
percent nail oh that's stuck the landing
oh that was not your personal best
though yeah all right all right let's uh
let's put some boosters on some fools
where are these uh black hand operatives
all right you're done I'm so sorry
you're not sorry though Oh what's yeah
that's like Grenada yeah see this is
what I would like I don't know this is
the good stuff all the traversing and
yeah it's really good I like it a lot
even playing just cause to and Just
Cause 3 you know this has been done
before but it I don't for some reason I
don't gotta nolde on me the the crazy
traversal stuff that you can do of
course I could just like shoot this
thing up but that's no fun all right so
what you gonna do I'm trying to retract
it maybe we should put some boosters on
it
oh no that's gonna do or you have it
snagged down right now so it's
definitely not going anywhere without
more blue suit oh whoa watch out Rico
Rico - suave Bob Jones says haven't seen
Michael on the streams in a while sup
Bob Jones
I've been busy man I got a lot of things
to do like man I don't think I'd ever
use my gun yeah I just kill them with
boosters if you were like stick them to
something or have something drop on them
cuz like why would I yeah if you can't
use the review tomorrow probably yeah
it's good Michael is the reviewer though
it is rare for me to have the reviewer
on the well I wouldn't say rare but well
more times than not because of the
nature of reviews I'm actually fortunate
that Michael had the time to do a stream
today but yeah I'm just gonna blow this
thing up Marv wants to know how much FPS
you getting cuz just cause always been
badly optimized I'm getting a solid 60
and through my review process like
playing the game on PC on a gtx 1070
1080p maxed out I've been getting a
consistent 60fps so I'm like yeah I
guess it's kind of messed those say like
oh I'm surprised that it runs well by
the time I guess I am but so let's use
the grenade launcher here
now I could take out that panel actually
oh you know whatever just blow it up
okay it needs to be done I need to move
on and make got to make sure I do it in
time so my homies don't die I mean that
also affects it I guess yeah but usually
your teammates have like a lot of health
like I've done a lot of escort missions
in this game and hardly ever do I run
into a problem I'm dying to fast fashion
so at least I'm thankful for that
wouldn't be able to speak on that yet
John Legend because we I don't think our
ps4 or Xbox one copies come in till
today so the reviews solely on PC yeah
I'm sure Michael will at some point try
those other versions just to make you
know check them out but yeah yeah
definitely I want to yeah I want to see
how it runs on like a base ps4
especially because Just Cause 3 running
on base consoles was not the business
yeah yeah we played it on ps4 right yeah
only PC I'm kind of surprised by the
performance I'm hoping it plays well I'm
nothing but also I'm spoiled playing at
us on PC because 60fps is like oh no
that's that's my fame man it's a shock
there's not more guys defending anything
I mean I don't the enemies in this game
aren't much of a challenge that is there
to like annoy the [ __ ] out of you
yeah but that's that's where I would get
all my shenanigans going you know yeah
I'd be like trying to booster one guy
into another guy or like you know tether
them together and then one guy gets
boosted and drags the other guy along
how many how many guys can we can we
boost away you know that's the kind of
crap IV yeah yeah we can try and get
creative a little later because live I
have all my things set separately
actually I can play let's see oh that
guy's dead I know he's not nice right
let's see one tethering with somebody
hold on man I could murder ya tomorrow
alright let's see what kind of weapons
are in here there's some pretty cool
weapons throughout this game this rocket
launcher is pretty dope I think we're on
all max right now cuz this PC is pretty
similar to the specs of what Michael
used it's got a i7 8700 K Oh Heather oh
my bad it's all good you I knew you had
a quake moment there yes the rocket
launcher with like quad damage actually
have boosters on this person bye-bye
what's the shoot at me now they're
shooting at the other get Gina alright
let's let's go alright get into the
multiplayer though right nah man I wish
there was which there was because I did
like that just cause to multiplayer mod
quite a bit and there's just so much you
do so much cool stuff in this game and I
wish there was a multiplayer playground
to do that kind of stuff so but you get
what you get and this is it yeah if you
guys want to know more about the review
you have to come back probably tomorrow
morning yeah I finish this game
yesterday and it's gonna take some time
to kind of wrap my head around it and
write my thoughts down in a hopefully
eloquent way well man can you do
something with that blimp in that ferris
wheel yeah actually enough will said he
wanted to ride the ferris wheel though
when we're done well too bad oh there's
well snap out a damn sniper there was
thought the red dot out there he is even
though I saw the like antenna
or whatever oh you're spider-man now oh
yeah
Rico is definitely spider-man so Mandela
yeah hey it looks like a guy's shirt a
destiny oh no that wasn't that didn't
look funny at all him trying to Wow look
how it keeps pulling oh because affairs
are the the merry-go-rounds to go in a
circle
oh that's messed actually hilarious oh
he dead
oh the boobs getting ripped where's
confronting others to blimps oh it's a
regular bloom there they're also
surveillance blimps that give you let's
take care of these fools actually who
trusts you to me oh this will God shield
well you know what
peace out dogs as I say you could rip
his shield off but uh actually that's
Heather doesn't stick to the oh really
yeah but what did six is like I would
assume I would oh yeah watch out
grenades it's all good you know they all
going on the merry-go-round oh you got
to sit us in oh well you he gets on the
merry-go-round to you go on the
merry-go-round
get him on yeah that that's the one he
wants to ride this is Red Dead
Redemption too baby he's on into it
sorry man maybe we can make this thing
go faster I don't know let's give the
horses some some boost ease oh it's
going the other oh it's fighting
different boosters you can I think
tether up to ten things clearly michael
has not taken engineering classes on now
man the the tethering targeting is a
little weird sometimes but oh you try
throw nades at me dog come on ah the
horsies what a killjoy oh you got one
horse going that's it man it's over for
you you're done son
peace oh he's having a good ride there
that's it that's a ride I pick oh yeah
look at fusion 360 noscope oh she's dead
Oh
boom oh yeah oh he's still alive
how really yeah cuz it's still red my
tart with my reticles red oh well and
that guy's the unbreakable know what
let's let's send you back up bye-bye
I got activated there you go why is my
balloons busting I said been
indestructible
alright whatever we should probably
finish this the side mission what do I
have to do I already go
I think oh my god my bad see that's the
thing I want to grapple onto the car but
auto target my homie I don't want to
anything sometimes it's messed up
alright let's get in let's finish this I
gotta bring him back
come on get in alright camera and
driving is a little weird
oh yeah a crime had asked the day I
hadn't proved the Wow what
yeah the driving mechanics themselves
are pretty good cameras of controls for
four years
that's weird it asked me to get in the
car and then destroy the things again
you're having too much fun this is cool
I like going around in this world I
don't want to bother in on these folks
so I'm not gonna not gonna send them off
to the sky yet yeah all right sorry for
disturbing your your lovely afternoon
here at the carnival at the pier
all right there we go success I said can
you destroy anything on this I would
assume you can destroy anything it's a
little limited like I can't destroy
these buildings here okay so you
selective so yeah I want tethering okay
Heather as many of them as you can
together then booster them up in the air
okay that's bother them and tether them
okay for anyone else anyone else up Oh
then tether them to the helicopter okay
and then tether y'all to the helicopter
and then booster the helicopter and then
boots with some flew these on the
helicopter I'm gonna put a random-ass
yeah do it
Oh going to the blimp please oh my okay
oh hey he recovered what oh damn this
pilot
you gotta give this pilot a raise the
fact that he could recover from that is
insane I know and look at those little
guys look at those guys there's a couple
one fell on the sand dude over or under
that he recovers this one - thanks good
dude he's good Wow I would have threw up
like five times already but this guy
this guy is on another level oh I still
shoot now me too
all right well you know what you're a
great pilot all but Heather hands in the
Feres man
okay yeah maybe Ferris wheels too far
let me get closer oh oh oh he's you know
himself up okay wait hold up okay or
that plane that water plane that's right
in front of you oh and then drive it
drive off with it oh yeah can you do
that
maybe a little far oh we've got the
Gatling guns on oh no [ __ ] just blows up
in this game right I don't know why I'm
asking that question it doesn't matter
why it just does all right that's fair
yeah I like it I like it
sorry okay so now you tether them and
drive away with them oh that's that's
like um in bread dough bread dad instead
of a horse you have a motorcycle
okay who else all right you're shooting
at me you're going for a ride too
yeah that's fine each other didn't do
the other guy that's totally all their
buddies are come all this is brutal
all right this is this is now the
motorcycle is hard to control now why
because people also it actually takes
that into account yeah this is good a
lot of things Heather while riding
can you tell while you're riding like
tether more oh no the tether button oh
my god
tether button makes me pull out my gun
oh my god I'm so sorry y'all you're not
sorry
are they still alive I doubt it they're
still alive
hell no they're not alive man no they're
not okay this does brutal
that's you'd be some [ __ ] up things in
this game and Rico does it without a Mel
phase look he's not even fazed like it's
just another Monday just another day
Rico's so tired in this game he's just
laying we got this [ __ ] again all
right what's next all right what's the
how do I get you to summon tornado can
you do that oh yeah let's try that I
forgot where the tornado base is was
trying
I wish so these are all the emissions
here I wish you could just go back and
do it again yeah operation wind Walker
also what do you guys come alive I'm not
buying this dude Deepak I can't believe
that helicopter somehow survived two
times of getting boosted like that but
you know it worked out an event it's uh
stuff out there I need to find where the
tornado base is I forgot where it was
actually hmm I guess this isn't much was
well I can activate the blizzard okay
this is Appa let's go there let's try
and do the blizzard it's a little bit of
a spoiler but I mean so the whole the
whole premise of this game is that the
the evil dictator you are taking down
this time can control the weather with
some crazy technology that so isn't it
like that James Bond movie then which
one are we control the weather or no
it's just that he could shoot like
lightning of this I remember I thought
it was you know the one where the Korean
guy turns himself white what the [ __ ]
dude it's pierce brosnan days
oh it's priest process oh yeah she died
another day
hey GameSpot dude on the left what's up
buddy cuz I guess I'm on the left
technically well in our studio I'm the
right he's the left but I think in the
picture-in-picture I am on the left
what's up cable one Kane the one I've
seen him multiple times he or she
multiple times and he's got he spits hot
fire sometimes to his own detriment
movie no Kane the one but he's got
opinions and I appreciate him sometimes
a little a little much but you know it's
all good he's pretty he's been pretty
good
Moonraker no that's hello old - so wait
are we in the tornado oh snap oh no this
is like Oh was that lightning yeah
lightning it's kind of all cuz it's
attracted to you right yeah it's like
some breast of the wild [ __ ] but damn
let me get out of this thing's okay so I
have activated the blizzard which
combines all three elements so there's
um there's sandstorms yeah oh you did oh
yes that's kind of cool I like that I
have to go really fast at the right time
to avoid getting lightning struck struck
by lightning yeah this is where the game
opens up also and it introduces you real
quick to the different elements so
there's sandstorms well there's uh
there's lightning and there is tornados
so when you combine all of those things
I guess you got a snowstorm
hey like lightning storm snow storm
combined alright let's turn this off now
it doesn't really there we go alright
cool that's how you can control the
weather just the press a few buttons on
the keyboard right there okay create a
blizzard I don't I'm not I want to mess
around I another day okay I said die
another day
did you yeah but I don't really remember
was I right though could he control the
weather in that or did he just have the
Lightning beam gun thing like a
satellite that I think he just had a
satellite that he could just use the
lightning from it's a box night it's
kind of like controlling the weather I
feel like he that's what he said but I
don't know yeah I mean investigate look
how beautiful wingsuit stunts oh let's
do a wingsuits done these are kind of
annoying the stunts he want to do it but
you said it's kind of annoying it's the
way the way these are kind of set up are
kind of annoying but let's try it out
all right let's see if I have better
luck this time let's get to the top of
this thing and let's see where this
wingsuit stunts wants us to go through
there so I got to go from there so the
wrong part is that it's only active when
I pull up my
my scan and the scan only lasts for like
a couple seconds so I gotta keep
scanning to keep the Rings okay
you talk to you telling me yes he did
have a satellite but it was more like a
sunbeam and not like lightning I got you
okay did he ever say he it was like he
was controlling weather though or am I
just like misquoting that somehow how
big is it says the kid how big is what
I'm guessing the world go with the world
of the map real quick we can check that
out later you can also doing a wingsuit
challenge oh wow
okay seems like that's how you kind of
level up one of your compadres yeah let
me explain that real quick actually
is there a jetpack I don't think so no I
mean you can't tether yourself but I
wish I could boost yourself how far you
like if I get nauseous just watch
actually that brings up a point I don't
put some boosters on a car and get in
the car okay okay so I gotta set my
boost these what car do I wanna boost
myself oh let's do this
this looks like a pretty slow car let's
make it go fast GTA all right they're
cool
all right y'all die another day they
could control solar rays looking up the
plot right now and which car that's
better thank you for your service right
all right here we go we're gonna follow
we're on spinners we're on spinners they
don't stop rod spinners Ron spinners
they don't stop and then you switched it
they see me rolling Hey
I'm so sorry if you guys are getting
sick from watching this I am gonna look
away in case oh you good are you gonna
die from this nope cuz I'm getting out
that's fair great job all right
that's tight doesn't exactly go straight
ahead but I mean I'm down with it oh boy
don't try it apparently there is a
jetpack in the digital deluxe and cold
editions or my gang chole what let me
see let me see how I ain't know about
this let me try it again
I want to put boosters on like every
direction of the car so it's gonna feel
like I got trolled let me see if it can
confuse confuse itself
all right I'm putting boots I don't see
that I think I got that I got rekt but
yeah I think this a lot of this game is
just about all the shenanigans all the
stuff you can do like all the crazy
things you know like all those GTA
online videos where you see people do
like crazy stunts and crazy like yeah so
I'm talking about oh my do we beyblading
now do we Dave Lading can we find
another card oh babe a blade with sure
oh that car survived it's all good man
oh I'm just gonna keep I'm gonna keep
driving it's all right cool that was fun
I haven't really so I've since I played
this whole game already I haven't really
found that many practical uses for that
kind of stuff maybe I just got to get
more creative get more comfortable with
it but yeah I kinda wish there was more
opportunities in the main story to do
those kinds of things were like almost
forces you to do it but yeah okay let's
so that's a snow area all right it's
it's really nice this game is I mean
it's technically got some graphical
glitches but art wise and like landscape
wise okay no one nas wants us to play in
class oh well we don't actually have the
console version so we're playing PC I
actually generally we Jen in in most
cases depending on what the game is we
usually get console first I feel like or
at least on at the same time yeah and
then we generally for me I play most of
my stuff on console there's only some
things I play on PC now but my home PC
is not so great I have to like upgrade
I've been thinking about it for a long
time and just haven't pulled the trigger
so now we're in the desert area
okay yeah okay let me see if I can build
some momentum there's a I think there's
a train mission here that I have from
Tsar hands oh but maybe we'll give it a
shot oh yeah it's right here can you
like tether and or booster the Train
probably right probably yeah
oh yeah assume anything is fair game and
Just Cause yeah show us the map oh yeah
sorry okay good so this is the whole map
you guchi you you start around this area
right here but then and then you can
branch out so since I have completed
this game everything is all the regions
are unlocked but when you start it's
it's set up as a like you unlock regions
with resources and all that stuff so but
yeah this is the whole map and you go
for this tropical area right here and so
this whole tropical air right here and
then more like coastal city that's a
little bit more a little bit more column
I guess you could say so all the bougie
people live airports right here it's a
pretty big map and once you go up into
this region here it's the desert area or
the snow the snowstorms the sandstorms
happen darude sandstorm happen there and
in the center here is kind of this snow
areas kind of where it all culminates
too so this is like the hideout of the
big bad dude
and he sits in this area and then so
this a portion of this area is
unexplored
in the beginning because it's covered by
a blizzard but you have the snow area
right here has got some really neat set
pieces so that's the whole map so the
pre-order digital deluxe edition has the
experimental black hand equipment
including including the black hand
stealth micro jet and the black hand
prototype weaponized wingsuit oh that's
cool
yeah the map is freaking huge yeah it's
pretty big
where's your mother this person yeah I
mean we were fortunate enough to have
get the game from you know everyone
let's see what's our handle wants me to
do today hopefully it's not another
escort mission it probably is doo doo
doo doo doo
take the sniper tornado it's not that
easy to find miss tornado apparently I
guess I'll I'll try it after this I'll
try and activate the tornado I just got
to remember where where that bass will
fly up here to get the sniper rifle
because we hit it up there thanks I
guess alright let's take that let's see
how good I am sniping with a controller
get to the army of chaos inside oh
inside the sandstorm dudududududududu
was it where's that okay it's right
there it's wingsuit down to the hull
Louise just now Scott we were actually
in a blizzard where there was like
lightning and all that stuff okay cool
tracks you like breath of the wild style
that kind of rings any bells
wait what oh oh well give me a sniper
rifle like dude you know you're next I
thought that was the bad guy I was like
maybe I was supposed to stay over there
yeah whoops oh we all got that our
tether tethers okay we don't need a
sniper all right hopefully I could do a
football okay before my homies kill them
missed it come on I'm not good with the
controller did you get him oh well they
killed him anyway these fools dead
already dead
yeah also fun snipers are like glass
cannons man what am I doing here
you're tethering those guys is that what
I'm gonna do all right
oops I hope you're done and let's send
you off into the stratosphere
oh the other guys holding them back
holding up down waving down man maybe
needs another oh come on I need to give
you another hog Lucy's already done
they're already dead what am i doing
sorry they're already dead Michael stop
damn I'm getting stuck on stuff
sometimes you just get stuck on things
ow
okay I don't know why I'm sniping now
but right in the gut
I thought you're trying to do something
like quick 360 no-scope tether drop in
quick scope boom headshot not with a
controller boom ran the nuts yeah my bed
boom so here's I guess is another escort
mission turns out I was gonna switch
weapons to my rocket launcher
what that allowed all right let's just
oh tethers only okay oh geez come on
come on come on come on activate all
right there you go what are these all
right they're not dead yet but they have
asked to be only one of them is alive
still okay well mommies are savages
they're just watch out he's got a rocket
launcher Thanks wait oh [ __ ] whoops
tether you two you and that one guy is
really gun huh Oh his head how come he's
still he's still alive that's why one of
them is
bye-bye oh my god wasting it's like it's
almost like you're said don't offer like
a duck hunt yeah yeah got your guys down
there you're almost like the dog that
laughs I don't want they don't kill him
this game is dark come over here
some scorpion type [ __ ] like it okay oh
and a heli oh I'm just gonna say Oh what
are you yeah peace out this doesn't have
any weapons on it but let's I'm just
gonna drop I'm trying
big money it just landed I didn't turn
off the engine or anything
not that I can the phantom phantom pilot
pilot found a way to like keep it alive
here ooh watch it toes breaking ankles
boom oh damn I guess my kick was lethal
oh I still gotta destroy it though
alright well I could do that what oh I
guess this off the sniper
I guess the smack right on the rocket
man I don't even know that cool air
lifter mod unlocked because oh and I can
drop a sniper or Alex five I guess maybe
okay so yeah I just did a bunch of
missions for Serhant oh and there was no
duty to do though
yeah there's no darude zin hear that
there was a darude their licensing so so
you have Sargento javi and Garlin and
there are the three people that you do
side missions for and the more you do
so I admissions for them you can unlock
mods for your grappling hook or
different ways that these things already
work yeah so for example let's see what
I can do is for the airlift now
so I can I can modify the gas it uses
and the peak altitude so for now I
already unlocked what type Armour has
its locomotion type that's why because
you have you have pot heaven Papa
there's one I want hover did you stay up
there forever so let me do a peak
altitude actually so I can set it to no
limit so that's good them them fools is
going to this forever they're gonna see
they're going to heaven they can see
what's up to God every time I kill
somebody I'm gonna send them okay all
right that's I feel like you're doing a
service sure it's fair right like you
should be doing that you got to respect
the dead I guess so you can the reason
why you would want I guess set peak
altitude is that you can set objects up
in the sky and then use those as vantage
points but there are so many buildings
and areas to grapple hook to that I
don't really see that as a I set those
up those traps and drop a lot you can
get creative if you maybe there's like a
no gun run yeah that would be pretty
interesting that would be pretty
interesting so now I'm talking about
yeah but for now no limit no limit
soldiers yep and here actually i'ma drop
I'm gonna drop something edit my loadout
there's all the stuff that you can drop
in supply drops but like it's hot
why what do you want I want to get a oh
you got a yeah like that you want to get
junk we stood or warship yeah you can
get some ships
you got it fighter jets you got
helicopters you got tanks tanks control
I don't know control you got some cargo
trucks so that from Metal Gear the
Fulton system yeah I guess but in a
different way here it's it's still like
yeah they don't just go back to the base
you know wait I'm gonna try and get on
the roof well actually I don't want to
should I get on the tracks I mean I need
a spot to launch from I don't think I
can use this sand oh yeah do I do it
like that swap movie where you do it off
the freeway okay sure
all right hopefully no cards come all
right so let's drop my said it black
hand units are on the way
Oh what oh people let's go y'all my
tether city
oh my jet how much land right there my
shed Oh what am i doing you get it
you're fleeing oh you're just so okay
you're just on fire oh my god
spider-man oh you still good though you
Rico never die Rico's invincible man
alright can I take this now please oh I
think I died dang that looks like a lot
of fun a lot of black hand to take out I
know those fools rolled up out of
nowhere man
I'm trying in my plane I'll let you get
your plane out
alright let's climb black it back up
this hill alright I want to show you all
the fighter jets and maybe I'll take the
fighter jet to where the tornado is
supposed to be okay by now so okay I
just call it I'll call out they're
actually not fighter jet let's do it on
the train tracks because I don't think
it's train is gonna come yeah we'll see
about that but am I surprised the
container didn't blow that one well I
guess it was more of a heavy-duty
vehicle but I want to call in just drop
bombs something I don't want an assault
rifle come on I want what that Oh sport
people's done vehicles combat vehicles
here we go it's got that micro fighter
back alright let's take off in this
direction can you comment about the time
how talked about time missions he put in
the extra words of bad and abundant for
time
missions but were those timed I thought
it was more that you had to keep them
alive oh those were there's a lot of
other other ones at our time yeah
there's like what's called region
strikes those are the missions to unlock
regions a lot of those are like time
things they blow this most of this much
stuff up in five minutes okay or make
sure you destroy these things before the
time runs out it's maybe this is a bad
idea yeah rails on there so I'm gonna
turn this thing around you gotta be like
that God God like helicopter pilot were
like you fall through the cavern or a
canyon just like find a way to lift lift
it back up maybe the the controls the
air controls in this game are actually
really good I like them a lot
careful Michael was being oh there you
go turns out he was a fighter pilot all
along oh no I don't do that I can touch
my wings a little but you can't you
can't turn and you kind of fall but
that's a few that's pretty cool I like
that yeah that's if you really need to
squeeze in a tight space but I don't
know if so we could have almost did
could you have boosted through the that
one track just now the train tracks
because you have turned here because you
suck wings baby as you're taking off
maybe wait oh my god okay this guy's
playing with a spire yeah
so yeah the plane controls are pretty
dope but let's find a place to go where
do we want to go where is that tornado
base man I'm so perplexed Prospero no
where is that base that's the damn bank
it was sit down here okay um because
that one mission ended in this area so
oh it's over here yeah some time about
me no event of all yeah that's where
that's where I want to go
so it's gonna take a little I could fash
travel I should probably backtrack oh
why don't you want to is a hella far
it's let's see I have to go from there
to there
how many how long do you think that
taking a nap it'll take a while it's
math fair enough so let me just how fast
raffle Nikolas come back in about a day
when Michael puts his review up and
you'll know if you should buy now or
wait for a sale yeah okay let's see if I
can activate my tornado here is this the
mine or I want to go to oh wait no this
[ __ ] this isn't it no got shovel again I
think this is it
I think that actually yeah that might be
a kick-ass travel from two hours it here
zone address yes that's where I wanna go
okay cool
there's three zones every new people so
said hello we're from the Bay Area
it's a expected for us to say that yeah
actually didn't know hella was a Bay
Area thing because I said a lot down the
Southern California yeah because that's
just part of how will that answer my
question yes yes that's like all right
let's see they said I can activate
tornadoes whenever I felt like it oh you
hate scared something happening Oh what
is going on oh yeah PTSD oh I'm sorry
man
oh it's because oh there's the black
handfuls oh wait no those are homies
maybe they're afraid of the tornado well
get out of here
yeah good try life is beautiful where
are our mods / bot is picking up
everything you're saying
so yeah I just basically use one of
these boosters on that guy and got him
on a chat
Oh what I'm fine that's messed up can
you toss a pre-order stuff I don't think
you have digital deluxe right so no I
don't think so damn Donovan that's such
such so much anger did you do that yeah
did not seem like you actually did that
but that's cool all right here we go we
got some tornado action oh there's a
helicopter to your right and there was
another one - I feel like oh [ __ ] what
am i doing
the worst word out there oh man let's
get it oh oh look at that look at that
look at that oh it's the homies
helicopter - oh damn I'm sorry no that's
alright I want to see that that's what I
came here to seek Oh baby alright if I
had oh oh my god Oh get off me
alright [ __ ] die there's an example
of how the crazy physics engine in this
game can work against you but hey try
again you can't get into it right
there's a mission where you can but I
don't know if that was just like a
cryptid thing yeah bring me higher oh
[Music]
you know like no Creed is there an
extremely Oh Pete gun in the game I
don't think you really need an Opie gun
when you can just like tether people and
get them yeah I mean he was using that
quad rocket launcher that thing felt
that was though I like that finish
strong Oh vape God take me in I like how
he's like disintegrating oh dude he's
face vape gods take me in almost your
personal best
almost we're at leaky lake yeah Wow
argue that hey man when Kevin was there
this is the kind of stuff you would do
you fly around real talk legit don't
don't don't give me they did tornadoes
before just caused a tornado sport oh
you're probably right
wow I can't see a damn thing are there
any cool special weapons besides the
lightning and wind gun a lightning gun
wind gunner private favorites I don't
think I haven't seen anything else to
toy around with
dangit Ben he's like yo I heard Creed
wow yeah that's a tornado and you can
activate it and well you put more stuff
into it right I think I can yeah it's
like it picked up one just stuff I guess
it's moving yeah as most tornadoes gonna
yeah it's gonna move across the the
landscape I think if I if I had a wind
gun I could probably push it but I don't
know where I can
oh it can I drop a wind gun actually see
if one of my Supply Drop homies can get
me one have you weapons oh yeah I can
drop a wind gun cool let's try that out
but first I got I got a drop drop it
like it's hot
let me add that go to this area
[Applause]
Dwayne Johnson says my q9 FN is waiting
for this masterpiece game funny thing I
was like dude q9f and sounds hell
familiar I was like alright we have that
TV out in the speed zone also the rock
is in the chat if you can believe that
also I don't think it's the rock baby
quick job right here give me that wind
gun
I hope my drop doesn't get affected out
we're all at we're on PC y'all do what
if it takes it ya know I'm worried about
I hope the tornado takes the package I
think that we legit oh man yeah I think
so I asked the drop it right here oh
there was a helicopter down there was it
was that the thing that was gonna bring
it to you I think so
wait cuz that helicopter just got swept
up in the tornado I think oh no I gotta
get I gotta get away be anymore
it was totally I saw a helicopter over
there but I don't know if that was gonna
affect your semester like what I did
anything they did Wow good save good
save good save
alright let me try this one more time
okay let it load out wind gun drop I
really hope it takes it again
because the there's a plane that comes
by to drop it off like that okay so that
helicopters not you those your friends
wait this to you're like just now left I
don't know what is going on they're like
dude do you know there's a tornado going
on I'm flying in that airspace I want to
get a wind gun oh yeah the use of
controller threw me off yeah he's Xbox
one controller I think this game is
actually like traversals a lot easier on
a controller Johnson is in the house
lads yeah he would never say lads
anyways yeah that's all right
tornado that's pretty cool so yeah why
do next let's say so we had mashaallah
blizzard sandstorm isn't that exciting
okay we saw well we saw kind of
lightning strikes through the blizzard I
guess we could show the sandstorm sky go
to Zona you know December's August
Arizona you know we just got boosted
again yeah you you you're just using the
using those oh man the bot mod thing's
already picking it up anyway so it's
like they're using the airlifters
more illegal gameplay the game is not
out yet and they are spoiled no I mean
illegal technically one we have the
review copy and to all those embargoes
that we know of have been limited so an
airlift is airlifted yeah even so Sith
Lord please be informed yeah uh come on
get with the program breath okay well
we're - right what do I need to active
also yes liquid identity brings up a
good players if you're worried about
spoilers so much yeah I mean come on
it's just cause it's it's got some okay
story elements but you know you don't
play just cause for the story I guess
but T great TV uh I don't know yet we
haven't played it on a default PS war
but I'm sure Michael go through a couple
iterations you know Pro yeah or normal
check it out on those platforms we're
currently playing on PC and that's what
he has so in his hands so yeah Oh
sandstorm here it is the routes coming
but but what about dude could you
imagine if twitch didn't exist and like
you know twitch brought back his career
man who Oh darude darude yeah he got all
these extra shows and all that stuff
just not really okay let's answer meme
oh man I forgot there was like a party
like or like a celebration for maybe it
was for dota one of the TI's or
sometimes at the internationals a couple
years back and like he was there playing
for it right
and he kept teasing sandstorm for like
the whole set and people just kept
waiting for sandstorm and it like never
came until like the end he just kept
playing little bits of it here and there
cuz like that's his like you know that's
his main song right so he's gotta save
it some strong brand right there
okay and this is the sandstorm so it
does some wild things to the lighting
and I can't really see anything there's
um there's
main story missions built around these
different weather conditions and those
missions are pretty dope okay
Itachi he asked in the weather can these
weather
or rather hold on exactly read what he
wrote can the weather only be created at
these bases what's the advantage of that
no no I was trying to paraphrase that so
since I finished the game the spoilers
all right well then yeah well I mean
there are the main story missions are
built around the weather effects and the
weather effects pop up every now and
then within the open world I think they
they come around and some of the side
missions to I believe okay one thing I
will say and I think this is like a
preview of my review is that and I wish
this game like these effects are really
dope I wish they'd use them more often
okay yeah it's like these are really
cool ideas but it's like man y'all could
have done a lot more with it mmm
does it I like gold chain gamers asking
is there a day/night cycles is there I
think so yeah yeah there's a day/night
cycle it's it doesn't really affect
anything but the time of day will change
Phillip our specs are i7 8700 K 1070 and
32 gigs of RAM I think those are the
most important things you'll probably
want to know okay
sidebar man says he wants some
destruction all right let's do it
I don't blame you this is this is just
caused so no some ish up should we do
should we do a mission then it's up to
you man I think missions are the best
way to you know universe so let's let's
see what Sorento wants me to do in the
in the snowy valleys yeah I can blow up
a blimp to they don't do that also
Joey pica I guess he doesn't have it but
I will ask did you get the golden gear
if so can you show it and the
Deathstalker stuff nope sorry
if I did I would show it where's that
balloon oh wow some I saw Blizzard out
here
I'm gonna go splat am I gonna go splat
personal best I uh actually I don't even
think you would have you would have died
before I had personal bests actually
whoops oh that's essentially a big big
oh and turn into a big rocket Oh get
those two things you see there we make
those balls I think these are too big
for my my tether no you got to believe
if I put bunch of retractors on these
put these boosters on them on one of
them okay it's uh what do you want to
boost them into each other or okay let's
try and boost one if you guys get some
of the things off of it some of the yeah
okay some of the pillars some of the
things holding up the structure there
for those asking can't answer too much
about the console stuff so
all right so railgun this is another one
of those special weapons actually like
quite a bit cuz they just go oh boy
let's go oh okay
this one's body and tether that one
piece oh [ __ ] or not no that's alright
we want it explosions let's see if I can
send this I want to send this thing to
outer space
Oh take off it's heavy it's it needs
help
come on lift Oh in if you ever wanted a
fourth of July here this oh I wanted to
get blown up on it okay
well this one's still intact he always
makes it through well I know we died a
couple times I know but he's back alive
alright so you're gonna try to get to
the top there's that blimp maybe oh yeah
maybe I could ride this all the way to
the top before it blows up and then get
to the blimp sure maybe I don't know I
think that blimps can see far away
though you might be right
let's go oh oh you're losing some are
tied to the rails
you lose ya must save this
oh you gotta get on there oh nevermind
you know why it's cuz the fire is
lighting that thing up I think well they
are fuel tanks oh alright alright what
is that Sorento machine let's go there
we go
FPS counter I mean we got to turn it on
with like and video we could yeah I
haven't seen a dip though really I
haven't really seen anything weird
except for like maybe in the sandstorm
you did kind of look a little weird but
you know what I mean yeah visibility you
could you could argue its visibility or
the lack thereof yeah I bounced ins Oh
where's my parachute there's popped in
so you do you tell you a grapple hook
and then parachute in parachute out kind
of like how you build momentum wow this
was over on the other end of the Rings I
should have took a helicopter alright
you're showing off other traversal yeah
it's still so I think it's so fun to
just parachute wingsuit combo all the
times actually I could just like I can
wingsuit it the whole time oh yeah fans
Oh close calls baby let's go alright so
cyborg man wanted some destruction
hopefully this mission will bring
destruction oh there's a helicopter here
too oh let's get it boy
alright alright there's your boys
destroy the explosive pinata oh wait is
this fortnight I think this is fortnight
man gonna blow up
how's this for getting shot worries oh I
can take a few bullets I'm Rico
Rodriguez man send this send this piant
pinata flying Oh goodbye
no it's hilarious is that it might not
even count oh you think it'll blow up
when it comes back down yeah I let it
destroy it
alright cuz you can manual set its own
whoa where's the other 100 drones that
that that is some quality these black
ops four coasters right here I tethered
them and then I think I'm gonna loose it
oh [ __ ] what Barry blew up no one still
on you right yeah one's dead and ones I
set a booster freaking out oh watch out
oh dude I switch off and bombs on you
though that's hilarious actually
oh that one's dead man this the tether
stuff is really cool I could destroy the
explosive pinata
you got it okay let's see airlift this
thing
oh maybe I can set it flying it's uh
send it forward whoa
I think I seen a blow-up though I just
watched it this time cuz last time I
don't know what the hell happened to the
last one it just went off yeah it's
still going
okay burnt out it's on a 10-second it's
gotta be making its way back I wish I
could tether myself to uh oh okay
what oh man did it do nothing it's it's
destroyed I guess but and weird I do one
of my friends
well my squad mates is getting shot up
they just chilling okay look at this
[ __ ] oh the AI is so Oh
the eye is so funny huh oh it's another
one okay he's not doing it in love
either
you can't shot by two now oh boy
nice next area let's go I need like a
practical weapon I only have like a
railgun practical weapon when you got
something that badass
no buts besides couldn't you just lift
those things anyways no oh the yeah the
minigun duh hey you gotta get creative I
know
when did the game come out technically
tomorrow oh yeah I gotta get out of here
good cool back at it again I guess it's
too heavy
well maybe you get booster it I'll see
- no wow those things really stuck to
the ground
maybe we can retract it pull it over
right here Wow
indestructible what about some boost
ease huh no one's been able to withstand
to put some boost bees doing that the
whole mine
this is the most powerful ma I've ever
faced it just caused for don't I said I
needs a rail gun yeah Wow
his I feel like this is a fortnight gag
you think so I don't know maybe possible
rail guns on these will last
pinatas Derek you see I got a blow them
up as one more Oh Phil - I - that No
there we go reach next area Oh groans
I'll turn you can boost you those yeah
Rico's Ian's dying yeah man he doesn't
give an F
he's like a terminator Rico is so
mild-mannered though throughout this
game he's just like I got to do this
[ __ ] again IRL iirc chairs can be bolted
in the ground so balloons probably won't
work yeah but there's no probably sure
where these balloons are strong again
those turrets are pretty powerful so
I'll give that see if I can do some
things with these explosive barrels
there's no nothing oh wait there's a
this in pinatas here but they're not
marked so I guess they're like for the
next batch or something I don't know
I like it damn I missed
oh well yeah won't you head on to that
next area this is a probably the last
mission we got or week and the stream
but should be fun times I even got it
probably no pre and post crime but we
will definitely have the PGA's on
YouTube on site Twitter Facebook bunch
of places let's come back Thursday check
that out let's go take this standard
assault rifle and I'll take this rocket
launcher wait I switched out the wrong
way whoops sorry
all right there we go
got to go back and kill some more it's
not the most exciting way to kill him
but it is the most efficient oftentimes
I find the most efficient way isn't the
most fun way to do things in this game
or minigames it control well with
keyboard mouse not really not at the
moment
but that's it's gonna be part of the day
one patch I think fine-tuning the
keyboard and mouse controls whoa
yeah fine-tuning keyboard mouse controls
I think is part of the day one patch
I've used the controller just because I
feel like the tethering and the
traversal is a little bit easier though
I always like 90% of time I play games
for keyboard and mouse and I'm there's a
lot of [ __ ] blowing up here not even my
line of sight
Wow okay cool so okay so the missions
I've been showing off are the side
missions that's not the most exciting
thing yeah I would say that the main
missions are a lot more a lot more
exciting they do make it do some cool
things but yeah cool some of the region
strikes are a little so yeah like the
region strikes are 31 of them and you do
them to unlock areas those are the kind
of the timed missions the escort
missions that some people aren't too hot
on and I was feeling the same way I'm
like and it could have been a little bit
more interesting
but yeah awesome a lot of cool stuff and
just cause for yeah and as mentioned you
know come back tomorrow gamespot.com as
Michael should be done with his review
by then ever a stole about an hour and
15 hour and a half of time from him from
writing is nice enough to come in you
know so come back for his thoughts on
the game now that he's being in but it's
pretty cool thank you guys all for
tuning in of course to GameSpot live
today we play just cause for we'll be
back tomorrow I believe I told Erin that
we do the battlefield 5 tank VLC cuz he
wants to do that
as mentioned Destiny's actually DLCs out
tomorrow too but just a quick heads up
for the people that do come by on
and more frequent basis like crime etc I
don't think we'll be live at 11 because
we have a like big kind of like meeting
here like the company like a company
meeting so I'm gonna try to aim to have
it before or after but the after might
be even later because we're starting to
do our best of the Year deliberations
and things like that so just know that
tomorrow won't be at our normal time of
11:00 a.m. but the rest of the week
on Wednesday Thursday and Friday we will
be back at 11 a.m. of course we're gonna
be doing stuff with the video game
awards as well on Thursday so come back
they're here if you want to check that
out as well
what else you got up to this week other
than that just cause for review I'm
trying to wrap up that just cause for
review and then some of the game of the
year stuff I'm gonna be participating in
some of the like best of the year my
best of the year sorry some of the kind
of like the wrap-up articles the
retrospectives that we have for the year
kind of pitching in on that but uh yeah
I'll have this review up soon I want to
get that done but so this is a Square
Enix published game so expect Rico
Rodriguez and Kingdom Hearts 3 just
saying okay that's hot take that's my
hot set alright that's fair and with
that hot take we're gonna get out of
here have a good rest of your Monday see
y'all later peace out good bye